you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's program
residents and tourists in athens are
evacuated as wildfires continue to burn
across europe
we'll analyze the current intensity of
heat waves and what that could mean for
wildfires in the uk
in the future plus the prime minister
has been told he is missing an action on
climate change as he visits scotland
ahead of the crucial climate summit and
the petrol price rise which could make
shift to electric come sooner than we
thought
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we
track the changes happening to our world
right now and meet those
coming up with the solutions straight to
europe now where wildfires are still
burning and forcing people out of their
homes
for a second day in greece acres of land
have been scorched
near the capital athens in a moment
we'll have a look at what these extreme
temperatures
could mean in the uk in turkey
fires are burning for an eighth day and
there is growing anger with the
government accused of failing to get a
grip on fires affecting parts of the
country
firefighters are cutting back trees to
stop their spread
the fires have been made worse by
unusually hot temperatures low humidity
and high winds and thousands have been
forced to evacuate
athens in greece where firefighters are
tackling huge fires in the north of the
city
the blaze has been made worse by what
greek authorities are calling the worst
heat wave in decades
with temperatures in parts of the
country reaching 46.3 degrees
celsius let's go to greece now and speak
to europe correspondent michelle
clifford she's in an area on the
outskirts of athens
um michelle hello to you what's
happening where you are
well there's been dozens of fires across
greece over the last
couple of days but the area around here
saw at the biggest
blazes we're about 20 kilometers from uh
athens city
and the blaze surrounded a village
called vari
bobby where i'm standing uh now now
residents were evacuated and when they
come back they're going to see some
really
quite horrific scenes this house behind
me is where a
95 year old woman and her 98 year old
husband lived it's completely uh
destroyed as
is the land if we look all around the
property everything
is completely scorched now this was a
family plot
their son lived in this house over here
that is incredibly badly damaged i spoke
to him earlier and he said
they were in their property yesterday
around lunchtime and they could see the
fires and they seem to be
a long way in the distance and then he
said within 10 minutes the fires were
on top of them and they had to drive
through the flames to get out now
800 firefighters overnight tried to
tackle
the blazes they were very intense today
they seem to have got most of the big
flames out the big problem though now
is that the whole landscape around here
is smoldering there is the potential
potential for more fires uh to ignite
and turn into something
really massive all over again okay
michelle thank you
well let's take a look at what's
happening in europe the south of europe
is usually the worst affected by
wildfires with countries like
spain seeing a weekly average of 80
fires in july between 2008 and 2020
but 2021 has been especially bad for the
region particularly
for countries like france and turkey
since the start of the summer countries
in southern europe have seen a surge in
the number of wildfires compared to the
same period in previous
years in italy for example at the start
of august the figures were already
double the average but the environmental
impact has been most pronounced for
turkey
which saw over a hundred and fifty
thousand hectares of land burnt at the
start of august
that is more than nine times the average
that was seen
between 2008 and 2020.
so could we be seeing similar scenes in
the uk well the june 2018
saddle worth more fires were some of the
largest uk wildfires on record and
lasted
for about three weeks at their peak they
covered an area of four thousand four
hundred and eighty acres of moorland
in 2019 there were fires in both maury
and keith ness in scotland that scorched
about
29 000 acres in northern ireland there
have been more than a thousand wildfires
in the mourne mountains over the last
five years and in april this year a huge
wildfire on those mountains was declared
a major incident
damaging 494 acres of land
let's speak to professor stephen durr
who's the director at the center for
wildfire research at swansea university
professor thank you so much for talking
to us
here on the climate show so what do you
think do you think we could see
similar fires here that we're seeing in
europe and turkey
well unfortunately not quite because
most of the fires we have in the uk
uh affect moorland grassland and
shrubland area so these fires tend not
to be so severe but sometimes we do have
forest fires occurring
and whilst we not yet have those extreme
weather conditions that we see in the
mediterranean
they're certainly becoming more severe
all the climate models
are in agreement that in the future we
will get more severe fire weather which
make
forest fires with big flames like we see
there more likely
and what would happen if we did see
fires like that
here well these fires as we've seen in
the media are extremely difficult to
control so we should do everything to
avoid
um extreme forest fires well what are we
doing if
are we mitigating in any way so that we
don't see the same situation here
well there are a number of things we can
do fortunately in the uk because nearly
all fires
here are human caused that could be by
awesome arson that could be by accident
and we can reduce the chances of those
ignitions we can also manage our fuels
more intensely so we can remove dead and
dry vegetation
in the landscape either manually or
using controlled fires which will
have a strong effect in reducing fire
risk
and is that being done not yet in the uk
uh in terms of let's say at larger
scales
but there are experiments and small
scale approaches in the uk where
prescribed fire for example
is used to reduce the flammability of
the landscape
under conditions when fires are not
extreme so in in the spring or
late in the autumn and this will then
help reduce the risk
uh during the summer and later in the
spring when the fuels can be very dry
okay professor thank you so much for
talking to us and staying with wildfires
in california a fire that has been
burning since june has intensified in
the last 24 hours
evacuations were ordered for about a
thousand people because of the dixie
fire
that's grown to over 395 square miles
across the plumas and butte counties in
northern california
so let's take you over to our data
dashboard now here at the top
is the real time powermix in the uk and
you can see renewables make up 38
and fossil fuels 43 and that of course
has an impact on global temperatures
this shows the human-induced global
warming
since the industrial revolution and it
is ticking up the whole time
the aim agreed by 196 parties at the un
cop 21 summit in paris in 2015 is to
keep this number
under 2 degrees preferably to 1.5
degrees of warming
this well this is the time left to that
crucial
1.5 degrees right to some other news on
climate change now and the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
has issued its hurricane season forecast
for 2021 they've predicted
that the likelihood of an above normal
2021
atlantic hurricane season is 65
with 15 to 21 named storms
scientists warned that warmer ocean
temperatures and higher sea levels will
make hurricanes more powerful and
destructive
posing a significant risk to public
health and to human lives
reusing and repairing household goods
could create more than 450 000 jobs
across the uk by 2035
the think tank green alliance found that
roles in engineering
machinery repair and administration
could be created while curbing the uk's
unsustainable throwaway culture jobs in
manufacturing are predicted to decline
but researchers say
funding redesign and repair initiatives
could ensure
future employment in the sector and
finally a study has found that 98
of emperor penguin colonies are in
danger of extinction by the end of the
century
if the antarctic continues to melt at
its current rate
that's because the flightless species
depend on sea ice to breed
and raise their young but the species
decline can be halted if warming is kept
to under 1.5 degrees celsius
compared to pre-industrial temperatures
well cop26 will be held in glasgow in
november and ahead of that boris johnson
is visiting renewable energy projects in
scotland
while on a two-day visit from today but
the opposition leader sakirshama has
already accused the prime minister of
being
off track to meet his own climate
targets
we need a strategic plan to enable us
to transition whether that's cars
whether it's energy
whether it's wind turbines here in
scotland hugely
important a strategic plan and what
we've seen
from the snp here and from the uk
government
is lots of targets lots of ambitions not
matched
by reality well let's speak to our
political correspondent joe pike
who's in fife um joe pressure on the pm
while he's up in scotland
certainly kimberly there is pressure on
boris johnson both
the prime minister and the labour leader
are here on two day trips
and remarkably similar in focus kirsten
nature reserve today
in glasgow talking about the run-up to
the cop
climate conference in that city
scotland's biggest
in november boris johnson today is
actually meeting policing leaders but
that has a
climate change link too because of
course the
force police scotland will be mounting
that massive security operation
around the conference protecting the
heads of state and heads of government
attending it it's tomorrow where boris
johnson will be visiting i understand
uh more climate change linked projects
saying uh the government is investing in
renewable energy
and in green technology as well
i think all of this does show that this
issue
has risen up the political agenda a
research
published recently suggests that the
biggest risk that
voters think that the uk faces is after
the pandemic climate change and
therefore they want their politicians
to explain how they are planning to
tackle it okay joe thank you
well one way to reach those climate
emissions is the shift from petrol to
electric vehicles and today it's being
warned that petrol prices have reached
an
eight year high in the uk but does a
rise in fuel costs
outweigh the upfront cost of an electric
car our business correspondent handling
smith has been looking into this
she joins us now so helena are the
rising prices going to have an effect
well it's really difficult to tell
kimberly and it's difficult to tell
because there's a lot of complicated
factors
going into this firstly that very high
price we're seeing at the petrol pump at
the moment it won't necessarily last
uh it's come about because of a variety
of complicated reasons but
problems at every stage in the supply
chain because of the pandemic from the
oil rigs all the way to the petrol
stations
and also a classic supply and demand
problem at the beginning of the pandemic
no one was driving and flying so much
the all-producing countries produced
less
uh now the economy's reopened everybody
wants more there isn't so much to go
around the prices go up so
that may not be sustained the other
reason it may not necessarily push
people towards electric
is of course what we always talk about
isn't it the cost of electric vehicles
because
even though an electric car is cheaper
to run once you've got
it that big upfront cost is still there
for people
and if you're the sort of family or the
sort of individual who's struggling for
an extra 20p or so
uh on the mile at the petrol pump it's
unlikely you'll be able to
uh foot that big bill for an electric
car now groups like the rac
they're saying that the government and
others should use this moment as a
big incentive uh to try and push more
people over the edge who were perhaps
already considering electric this is
what they had to say
perhaps there is an opportunity now to
really capitalize on the the lower rates
that
ev drivers can you know can enjoy and
get more people into those
but the answer really is around kind of
flooding the market with new electric
vehicles
we know at the rac that most drivers
still buy their cars
second or third hand so the only way
those drivers are gonna be able to
afford electric ones
is if there's enough supply at the top
well that's everything from us
today on tomorrow's show green gaming
how developers are using games to
inspire players to make changes to their
own lives
thank you for watching see you then
[Music]